and I just want to say I do understand
the defensiveness of Men In This Moment
In a lot of respects and I know it's not
a good thing to group all women into one
of course there's going to be outliers
there's going to be great women out
there who they don't need to be
defensive with but I understand the
Instinct right now because we're living
in a time that repeatedly demonizes men
you know and I always reference the
Justice Kavanaugh trials and what they
did to him it was horrible the
assumption that he was guilty the the
criminalizing him on second one with no
evidence I think men often feel and
rightfully so that they're under attack
toxic masculinity these terms are out
there so they feel like they need to
defend who they are what makes a man a
man I mean you can't even say the word
man and woman anymore we're living in
such a crazy time and I think I relate
it to politics in the same sense that I
feel defensive against the left right
now because I'm watching the left wreck
cities around the country
I'm watching crime I'm watching these
once beautiful neighborhoods I'm
watching New York City my hometown get
destroyed so I'm now at a point where I
feel like people and I get it are saying
enough like I'm not signing up for that
I don't I'm not playing your game I'm
not playing nice with you anymore
because you're out to deplete me the
things that I value the things that made
this country great and one of the things
that made this country great is an
acknowledgment that men and women are
different and we each bring different
beautiful things to the table but if you
remove that
and you discredit men and now all up
everything that that they are proud of
as far as their masculinity is labeled
toxic that's a problem that's a really
really big problem so I do understand
some of the defensiveness 100 and and to
me you know doing what I've been doing
for such a long time I've told people
this you can go back to I have YouTube
videos from 2012 where I'm talking about
these topics and issues about what's
plaguing man I've been really passionate
about helping see men's lives
transformed since I was 19 years old I
was elementary school teacher preschool
teacher High School teacher and middle
school teacher I've taught men at all
ages and I also mentored kids in college
so I literally I've told people like if
there's anybody who understands the
struggles of men there's me I brought in
all the different experts from Dr Jordan
Peterson's Dr Warren pharaohs and Dr
Jonathan Heights I brought in all the
leading experts to talk about these
issues so I'm extremely well versed and
passionate about everything that you
said but but here is the uniqueness this
is this is where I've changed my tone a
little bit because it's yes are men
under attack yes are men being shamed
yes is it are they shaming men in their
masculinity yes do men are having less
rights yes what do we do now
what happens is what I find so often in
the internet is they just want to stay
there let's just do all our content
about what's wrong in today's world
what's wrong what's wrong what's wrong
we know it's wrong now what do we do
because there's a difference you hate
New York City is garbage trashed liberal
policies that you can't stand leftist
policies that you can't stand you want
to leave and you come to another a
different place right you move but
here's the difference between men and
women men and women can't move and get
another person you know I mean there's
no other there's no third or fourth
species you know like there's none of
them
robots the robots are coming no so to me
it's like we have to find a solution
that's what I'm passionate about
nowadays we know the problem like I've
been on YouTube for how six years we've
been talking about they've been some
people are literally making their money
talking about the same problem every
single day let's talk about Solutions
and so to me that's where I understand
that what men are going through how do
we solve this that's what I'm obsessed
with right now if you want to watch the
full episode click right here and if you
want to ask me a question talk
one-on-one send me a FaceTime video join
a video with a group of your friends and
me you gotta download manect and you
gotta join me there it's gonna be really
hot
[Music]